so you said uh again dostoyevsky kind of
was exceptionally good at getting to the
core of what it means to be human
do you think about like the why of why
we're here the the meaning of this whole
uh existence yeah no i i do i think uh
and actually think that's the purpose of
an education
what does it mean to be a human being
and in one way or another
uh we set out to answer those questions
and we do it in a different way
uh i mean some uh may look to
uh philosophy to answer uh these
questions why is it in one's personal
interest
to um to do good to do
just uh to do justice uh
some may um look at it through the
economist's
lens some may
look at it through the microscope in the
laboratory that the phenomenal world
is is is the meaning
of life uh others may say
that that's one uh vocabulary that's one
description but the poet describes
a reality to the same degree as a
physicist
but that's the purpose of of an
education it's to
sort of work through these issues what
does it mean to be
a uh what does it mean to be a human
being and i think it's a fascinating
journey and i think it's a lifelong
uh endeavor to figure out what is the
thing that nugget
that makes us uh human do you still see
yourself
as a student of course yes i mean that's
uh that's the best part about going into
into
university teaching you're you're a
lifelong student
i'm always learning i learn from my
students and with my students and
uh my colleagues and your you continue
to read and
and and learn and and modify opinions
and i i think it's just a wonderful
thing
well ron uh i'm so
glad i that uh somebody like you
is uh carrying the fire of what uh is
the best of harvard so
it's a huge honor that you spend so much
time waste so much of your valuable time
with me i really appreciate it not a
waste at all
i think a lot of people love it thank
you so much for talking today thank you
you